a review not really a rant yes is if
you're gonna rant about the butchering
of a great song do it in HD swells
watching the Superbowl I'm not really a
football guy not really a sports guy I'm
a nerd as you know
hockey's cool though and the halftime
show comes on and the black eyed peas
are coming out and I'm thinking okay
it's gonna be entertaining if nothing
else
so the peas come out and they start
singing singing I'm looking around going
it looks like Tron which means Daft
Punk's coming out right and holy [ __ ]
that sound like a bunch of people just
screaming in microphones like the first
eight episodes of American Idol yeah
like that and one of them looks like
bebop from Ninja Turtles he comes on
purpose today cool it looks like Tron
which means Daft Punk's coming out right
and then I heard it sweet child of mine
slash comes up from the stage looking
like Rob Zombie and the Mad Hatter's
love child's play a sweet child of mine
I'm like this is gonna be badass
thank God in my opinion one of the
greatest songs ever and then Ferg he
starts singing and she sounds like she
has balls
what did the Wachowski brother cut his
off and give him the Fergie she was like
but the Loden in the basket memory she
sounded like the lotion in the basket
guy from Silence of the Lambs best I can
describe it I mean you could have had
like Adam Lambert seeing it that would
have made sense he sounds kind of like
Axl Rose and he's a big name right now
instead blue trend and American memories
but it still looks like Tron so Daft
Punk's coming out right and then uh sure
comes onstage which I'm pretty sure it's
almost like yeah uh sure yeah can you
get here like right now like right now
yeah she's a butcher and sweet child of
mine you might not give a [ __ ] but
please get here right can you have Jim
Kirk like transport you so Usher's dance
and he's picking up the pace it still
looks like Tron which means Daft Punk's
coming out right
apparently evil winds in the world and
the peas came back pain yeah Fergie's
voice sounded a little better after that
but I'm pretty sure she was hammered if
you look at her eyes I know what a drunk
person looks like I have been one cuz
we've all just been in the bathroom when
we're hammered we've been like oh like
this against the mirror and you look at
yourself and you're like you're so drunk
right now
Fergie in the halftime show and then
fireworks went off and it was done no
death Punk whatsoever yes they're just
cashing out on the Tron thing thanks
Disney I mean if I were like deaf or
something I would love it looked great
looked great sounded like Helen Keller
do to do it
no telling the Green Bay Packers one
does I mean there is that a sweet child
of mine died today so as you watch the
Super Bowl did you see the halftime show
what did you think about it pretty sure
I'm not alone on this comment below let
me know New Kids on the Block would have
been cool Tiny Tim and his ukulele would
have been way more awesome but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
now in HD and [ __ ]
[Music]